um now I saw you perform at the comedy
store
12 years ago
I think it was 2010 and it in your set I
still have the same set
same jokes and in the set you were
talking about
um your uh your huge movies and the one
that you did with Brendan Frazier
and you were it was very
self-deprecating what you were doing you
were talking about how you uh when you
made this movie whether there be an
Encino Man with with uh Brendan Fraser
you made that movie you guys were that
you were the star of the movie
and that after that you were describing
how Brendan Frazier's career just from
that point like went crazy you know and
you were kind of putting yourself down
as uh you know like he was the one who
really like like went skyrocketing and
and uh I remember thinking to myself why
is Paulie up there like bashing himself
like this describing himself as the guy
whose career went downhill uh Brendan
Frazier's went so up and now 12 years
later it would seem that uh that that
those courses have reversed you know
you've got the guest house the one of
the most watched movies of of 2020
there's like a a Resurgence in Pauly
Shore the stand up is still going and
yeah I don't know um I like
self-deprecating humor yeah so um I like
making fun of myself I like playing the
victim you know I think Pauly Shore's
dad was a great example of that you know
um I don't know I I'm very I'm very
aware of my surroundings you know I'm
very aware of you know the fact that I'm
not starring in movies you know you know
I I did star in a movie but I'm not
starring you know what I mean I mean I'm
working all the time but it wasn't like
it was you know what I mean and I'm
aware of that so I like to make fun of
it in a way I mean do you you are yeah
like I mean when you started on MTV you
were 19 I was probably about uh my first
time ever yeah it's not early 20s yeah
yes I went so what what year would it
have been when you were first on MTV uh
early 90s yeah so my run on there was uh
like 90 to 97 around there wow yeah and
and that was just well it was it was
insane I mean it was you know it was I I
say that I have uh uh it's like Willy
Wonka you know what I mean like I got
the golden ticket I was in my 20s I was
starring in movies I was on MTV HBO
MTV led to the movies yes yeah yeah it
was it was it was big you know it was
big
um and um
you know it was so big that it had to
stop you know in a way but I was also
and I've said this to people you know
sometimes I make decisions emotionally
and not with my head you know so what
happened was and I talk about this in my
one-man show I have a one-man show
that's doing really well right now in
Vegas all over okay yeah we just got
into the New York comedy film festival
that's going to be being another month
or so but um
you know when things like when my sitcom
didn't get picked up and and and and you
know and I was trying I was uh
transitioning from a boy to a man you
know or at the time I was 30 I was just
like I just wanted to get rid of
everyone in my life meaning managers and
agents and all that stuff and kind of
just go away and then when I try to get
representation you know a year or two
later everyone was like this they
weren't into it so then that's when I
went to therapy and then I was able to
laugh at kind of what I went through and
that's when I did Pauly Shore's dead
which to me is the best thing I've ever
done if you haven't seen Pauly Shore Is
Dead it's [ __ ] like it's very dark
and it's very funny but it appeals to
people that don't like me and it appeals
to people that like me but everyone's in
it and it's um how do we see that it's
just everywhere it's on um I don't know
it's uh I guess it's just on if you go
on Amazon or YouTube or whatever it's at
but everyone's in it from Dr Dre to Sean
and uh with the Goldberg I mean there's
like Eminem
wow but it's Britney Spears it's just
like it's it's basically the premises I
fake my deaths become famous again and
and then I wind up becoming Fame that
people find out that I'm not dead and
then they want me dead and then I wind
up in jail with like Tommy Lee so Tommy
Lee's in jail with me so it's a movie
yeah it's a mockumentary wow Carrot Top
moves into my house but it's all played
very real and that's not played goofy
when did this come out it came out in
2003
damn yeah and it's [ __ ] it's called
Vince Vaughn's in it and Tommy Lee
Britney's friend Britney Spears in 2003.
yeah Britney Spears is in it because
Larry Rudolph got was what was the
production company for that I produced
it I directed I wrote it I paid for it I
did it all myself well I'm sorry in a
20th Century Fox picked it up wow but
it's it's to me it's the best it's dark
and [ __ ] I'm in I'm in solitary
confinement in the in [ __ ] Adam
Sandler's voice comes in he's like
weasel
and I start crying and I got [ __ ] the
ghost of Sam canison appears it's
[ __ ] gnarly dude like it's a gnarly
gnarly film and then I'm always like uh
trying to figure out something epic to
watch while I'm on this video yeah watch
this Ben Stiller's in it but it's all
played real so when you watch it you're
like [ __ ] did he die
like yeah man that's so and I did so
incredible to me yeah
um and presumably you just had like um
all these people were fans of you or you
had relationships with them they were uh
just did it as favors yeah they kind of
it's like once they got Sean Penn in it
I was able to like you know it's not
like dominoes it was dominoes after that
like I got real Tenon I've known him for
for years Sean Penn I've known for um
since we first started back in the day
he said something to me one night that
really that really kind of landed with
me so we were at the um um we're at the
Chateau Marmont and we were I have some
great Sean Penn stories
we're going up to a suite and we're
walking with a couple girls or whatever
and Sean Penn turns around he looks at
me and he goes I don't know what it is
about you it goes but you you make me
laugh
and I'm like huh he goes your shit's
Universal dude you're [ __ ] just so
you know I think you're hilarious yeah I
was like you know what I mean and this
is Sean Penn and then we continue
walking so I remembered that so I called
him on it so when I pitched him the idea
I said yo I'm doing polisher is dead I
told him the premise and he's like I'll
do it no problem so I flew with my
friend Kirk Fox you know Kirk the
comedian sure yeah so he's in the scene
with Sean Penn and we flew up to San
Francisco and we just shot it and then I
[ __ ] got that tape and it was just
like if as an independent filmmaker
you're like [ __ ] I got Sean Penn and
then I actually did a documentary called
once they got Sean Penn about the making
of Pauly Shore's Dad wow which is you
know and then mini me's in it [ __ ]
Burns in it yeah like he plays my
neighbor I almost run him over it's like
it's like non-stop Kato Kaelyn's in it
he's got a comb over and [ __ ] and you
know because he was famous for his hair
sure but yeah Pauly Shore Is Dead is
like that was that to me he was the um
the the the polishers there was the
beginning part of the second part of my
career okay so because once stuff slowed
down then I started producing my own
stuff and and I've done so many things
by myself with all of those people in it
yeah like uh
like what was the budget that you made
it for I think it's like 800 000. oh wow
okay so that's not yes but yeah I spent
some money you know and then uh you know
like did you like
triple it no we kind of broke even maybe
a little bit more wow okay but it was
but it was it was you know it was cool
you know it was cool it's called Stevo's
hot sauce for your butthole and if you
go on Amazon and type in Stevo's hot
sauce for your butthole and Order
yourself a bottle you'd be really
helping me because right now we're
ranked number 30 on all of Amazon and if
you buy a bottle we might go up the
ladder and that would mean a lot so
please get on Amazon and buy Stevo's hot
sauce for your butthole yeah
yeah dude